hey i'm alvin i love steaks and i love
mario party i've always wondered what is
it like to play those mini games in real
life and today we're going to be playing
a mario party mini game sizzling steaks
it's crazy it's intense and somehow you
cook a perfectly cooked steak in like 10
seconds my area of expertise is food so
i thought it'd be fitting to bring in a
video game expert this is zach from
buzzfeed multiplayer hey yeah i am uh
not a cook at all i play video games a
lot so i think it's only fair we play
mario party first i think that's a
fantastic idea all right let's do it all
right let's go
so the rule is you have to cook all six
sides of the cube and whoever is the
fastest wins the catch is you have to
only use flipping it with the joycon
basically meat doesn't blame like that
so we're going to see how it's going to
play out safety first got to have safety
everyone pans are flying the stakes
going everywhere yeah oh
the nerves are kicking in
i don't think i'm gonna have a pan all
right this is a perfect circle of oil in
the middle okay all right start oh drop
the steak yeah okay cooking aside one oh
i got two okay this is the most
non-stick pan i've ever seen in my
entire life i only have one more okay
what how did you go so fast
once i you got it oh my god you're so
good exactly
well uh to try to replicate this in real
life i think i have a bit of work cut
out for me but i'm gonna do the best i
can
we work with the culinary team to try to
replicate the game as much as we could
there's a little plate of food on the
side and nice plants because i think
that's how mario likes his cooking setup
how do you feel about all this i'm blown
away this is literally exactly like the
game this is a boneless short rib um
it's a really nice cut of beef i think
it's got really nice marbling the muscle
fibers are nice and even i'm just going
to cut through and get really sharp
slices because we want it to be a cube
yeah you see that
wow sharp corners it's kind of cool
right i'm going to go freeze these and
we're going to cameras in here to get
that set up excited yeah let's do it all
right let's go
all right so yeah we are ready the
cameras are here the angles are set up
pans are heating we're pretty much ready
to go i'm gonna put some oil in because
i think the oil also needs to be hot for
the sake to sizzle so i'm just gonna use
some nice vegetable oil
okay yeah zach you want to put some oil
in yours you want me to do this yes i
want you to do i know there's smoke
coming up but that's a good sign okay
okay so tell me when keep going
keep going all right you're good you're
good mine's going a lot water mine's
going more than yours before these get
too crazy i'm going to season these
steaks really quick okay wow these pans
are smoking whoa the goal of the game is
to cook each side until it's brown yeah
i don't think it's fair where the judges
of our own stakes so we have a special
guest judge rea
hello
she will help us determine whether or
not the stakes are brown on each side so
that this is an even playing field but
for safety we want to put on some
goggles because we don't want to make
sure any oil splashes out because in the
game you don't have to worry about that
when you get goggles for something that
like
truly is like oh you are in danger oh
these smell weird yeah
all right oil's hot i'm ready zach are
you ready i'm ready reid are you ready
i'm ready but i'm gonna step aside
just in case please do not do this at
home ready ready set
go go oh boy oh nice guy oh yeah after
the game
go like this
oh oh oh oh your mine's already kind of
moving i'm gonna go for a flip here
already
oh okay yeah what do we think here it
looks good but i want a little bit more
crust more crushed i gotta redo it send
it back and that maybe you want to put
on the whole plate leave it leave it
there on the air leave it there okay in
the game you're always just
constantly moving just like this and i
think i took that hannah to heart i was
like yeah i'm gonna finish in 20 seconds
you want okay is that of course
showboating a little i'm gonna try it
okay it turned i won't come back over
it's really rolled you know yeah is that
a good crust let me see i like
that one on the top okay so everything
should look like the one how's this
looking this one what do you think i
like the one on the side oh there's the
one on the side
oh that one looks good okay let's do
more of that mine's turning into a tube
i have one side that is just red mine
looks like seared ahi tuna yeah but i
should have cut yours worse than i cut
mine
and we'll see that i'm going for a big
one all right come on no no no terrible
you drop it it won't just poop in the
air
wait the shampoo is important no unless
i get extra credit i cannot get the last
side for the life of me your side is
it's like it's way too hard i don't
think
wow this is
so much harder than the game how much
time have we this is so far so this is
very hard i'm so mad i can't get this
piece see in the game everybody's stakes
looks the same you don't have to deal
with this kind of stuff i'm just going
to go off the side of the pan there yeah
what do we think of this
good
good and good what
sunk is a
well done well winner
that was a
pretty wild i feel cheated even though i
know i'd cut my own steak well in the
game there's like a sauce that goes on
the plate so i'm going to use the fawn
from the beef to make a little quick
like deglaze sauce and we're going to go
into tasting after that do you know why
it's fun oh no no
don't worry about it
[Music]
all right so we have orange juice just
like in the video game these steaks are
plated and i've made a quick soy honey
glaze just to kind of emulate the dark
sauce on the plates so let's start here
and go around look at that
this is the smallest steak i've ever
seen if i ever serve this at a party i'd
be pissed yeah and i think now it is
time for a taste test really our special
judge um if you may please yeah ah this
is like
every cooking show and they cut in
you're like please be the right
temperature this is so small it's very
difficult to cut
whoa that looks perfect too oh my gosh
perfect rare good job dude thank you
nice
oh okay yeah does it taste good
this would have nothing to do with me
because you seasoned it oh she's nodding
her head mm-hmm yeah
yes
wow
next
yeah yeah oh thank you yeah oh cool
that's perfect forget gordon ramsay i'm
gonna use mario's
six cube side steak method
good
i mean it tastes exactly the same yeah
so you guys are both winners
[Applause]
oh if you guys have any ideas for other
games that involve food that you want us
to try to replicate in real life let us
know in the comments we're gonna keep
eating this steak yeah this is good it's
actually a really good steak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you